Europe was still in the Dark Ages.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here again, and
today I wanna talk about what I call
the magic of language learning, the
emotional side of language learning.
Now, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So, you know, in my previous
video I talked about how important
it was to reward ourselves.
For every little thing you do, every
time you are able to do something
in the language, reward yourself.
But there's another aspect to
rewarding yourself, and that is to
indulge in those things that make
the language interesting to you.
And even if you are not doing these
things in the target language, if you
are cultivating that interest, if you
are cultivating the magic, you are
going to motivate yourself to learn
the language, and I wanna talk about
some examples from my own experience.
So first of all, when I started
learning French, I had a professor
who made French culture French
civilization, very interesting to me.
As a result, I started
watching French movies.
Prior to that, I wasn't interested
in French, even though we had it
at school and so I couldn't speak.
And then when I followed my
interests In French movies, French...
everything to do with France,
and eventually ended up going
to France, that spurred me on.
The same with Chinese.
I got very interested in basically the
modern history of China, the twenties
and thirties as China struggled, sort
of coming into contact with Western
civilization, Western imperialists.
Uh, a very proud and, and old culture
having to face certain new realities.
That whole romance of that period
motivated me to learn, uh, Chinese and
I can go on and on with other examples.
Russian, when I watched ... a movie,
a Russian movie from the 19th century.
Uh, it conjures up this romantic
image may not be an accurate
reflection of what Russia is or was,
but it's part of what motivated me.
It becomes the, the sort of
magic, the emotions, because
emotions are very important.
We know from cognitive science research
that when we learn something, if the
brain sees things that are new and
meaningful to the brain, the brain is
more likely to remember those things.
And so that emotional side, that
emotional connection is important.
I find that if I listen to something
in the target language and I enjoy,
I like the voice, I enjoy the subject
matter I'm more likely to remember,
I'm more, more likely to learn from it.
Another example is my current
experience with, uh, Persian,
Turkish, Arabic, that, you know,
central Asia, middle Eastern world.
So in addition to what I do on LingQ
where I study and I explore some
of the great content that we have,
for example, in Turkish and in, in
Persian, that Sahra has prepared for
me on Iranian history and so forth.
I also indulge my interest
by reading in English.
Uh, so I wanted to show you some examples.
So here's a book for example about Selim,
who was one of the great emperors of
the Ottoman Empire and how he, you know,
killed his brothers and fought to gain the
throne and what he did with the throne.
I just started into the book and it
is fascinating, uh, and it conjures
up that Turkish world, the Turkey
connecting with the Safavid, the Shiite,
uh, forces in, uh, next door, Iran.
All of that is part of
that Turkish/Iranian world.
And as I get into that, of
course I get into the whole
magic again of Central Asia.
Central Asia a thousand years ago
was a major center of world learning.
We sometimes forget that, uh, at a time
when, uh, Europe was still in the Dark
Ages, there were scientists in Central
Asia who were measuring the stars
and, you know, the orbits of, of , you
know, planets and this kind of thing.
Uh, and their language was Persian.
In fact, here's another book.
I, I, I tend to go buy books because
I, I want to indulge my interest
because that then motivates me to
work harder on my Persian, my Turkish,
my Arabic, um, The Persianate World.
Um, one that I started into, by the
way, is The Lost Enlightenment, which
again, deals with very specifically
this Central Asia Bohara, uh, Samarkand
center of learning for quite a few
hundred years, which contributed to
the modern world as we now know it.
All of that is a bit of a digression
and a distraction, but I don't
begrudge myself the time that I spend
reading in English about all of these
things because it motivates me in
my learning of these languages and
my discovery, uh, of these cultures.
Because inevitably when we learn
the language, we discover culture.
We discover new areas that previously
were perhaps a collection of
stereotypes come alive for us.
So I suggest you do indulge your
interests, whatever they may be.
It might be Anime in the case of
Japanese, or K-Pop in the case of
Korean, whatever those interests are.
Or if you wanna watch a movie with, you
know, subtitles in your own language,
even if you don't understand much.
This was the case when
I started into Russian.
It's, um, it's, it may not do that much
for your language learning, but it is
stimulating, it triggers that interest and
that's so important in language learning.
And I did do, uh, a couple of
videos one 13 years ago, one nine
years ago on the importance of
our emotions in language learning.
So I suggest you have a
look at those as well.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.